welcome to podcast Ville this show is
brought to you by lift when you drive
for the right ride-sharing app every
trip can feel like a walk in the park
with lyft you can pick your own hours
and drive when you want lift can make
driving the best gig in the world and
I'm telling you it is so join the
ride-sharing company that believes in
treating its people better go to lift
calm right now / Joey today and you get
a $500 new driver bonus that's lift calm
/ Joey today and I'm gonna get you a 500
our new driver bonus limited time only
and terms apply check with lyft it's the
way to go this show is also brought to
you by my [ __ ] favorite
birthday in the world - she Thanksgiving
is the time to express gratitude and
recollect on what you're truly grateful
for it's also a time when you invite
your [ __ ] crazy family members into
your home to eat up your food and they
[ __ ] this [ __ ] in your bathroom and they
[ __ ] use on that this year make sure
when your family shits it's in the
[ __ ] house and they leave with the
[ __ ] clean ass get to she bidet I'm
gonna do this for you $69 with a
risk-free 60 day trial $69 with a 60 day
trial listen you don't want your [ __ ]
Uncle Louie walking around with that
gravy s because all you had was that
[ __ ] stick your finger in the toilet
paper toilet paper correct so gonna push
you right now to see doctor hello - she
calm right now and use the code church
and I'm gonna give you 10% off your
order so go - hello - she's calm and use
the code Church CH you are CH for 10%
off your order take that [ __ ]
muley
[Music]
you
oh [ __ ] you bad [ __ ] Wednesday
November 1st you understand me you're
like what 55 days away from Christmas
and you're sitting there thinking about
your next [ __ ] move you better get it
together [ __ ]
the years gonna sneak up on you quick
and you're not gonna know what [ __ ]
hit you anyway welcome to the Church of
what's happened now it's old school
today myself and my little trusted
[ __ ] [ __ ] the original Lisa
at the one and only the one and only
mother [ __ ] I want to thank all you
[ __ ] for selling out Omaha this
weekend there's nothing left one show
Friday to show Saturday and next week
you [ __ ] sold out in New York
already so I guess we're gonna blow that
[ __ ] block up I hope that poor little
[ __ ] whatever don't live upstairs
don't walk okay left in New York
immediately after that we can then close
the window he said stolen [ __ ]
YouTube anyway I want to thank you
people it's part of New York Comedy
Festival and I'm honored I mean you guys
got Segura and [ __ ] our boy run white
what who I would be going to see if I
live in the funnel run why don't waste
my time with Joey Diaz but thank you
anyway you got iliza shlesinger yeah lot
of [ __ ] so I'm pretty happy
that it all worked out I'd love Gotham
you know the VIP parties the pizza joint
down the corner 50 yards away from
Gotham it's always simple with uncle
Joey there's no nightlife for V the VIP
parties at the pizza place whoever gets
there first kills the first Reese from
boley's that's the rule and we were
right from there uber shows up right to
the pizza joint you're right back over
the [ __ ] bridge nobody knows nothing
you have all three nights already been
already planned planned I had all four
nights already planned
meet with my [ __ ] buddies Wednesday
night Thursday I'm gonna Brooklyn with
Ari I'm coming back with a stop it at
the [ __ ] City
then Friday Saturday we got Gotham
bing-bang-boom no [ __ ] around what am
i and that's it I'm pretty much done for
the year
I got a ravine the night before
Thanksgiving
I got Sacramento when I got my ear
surgery so I'm pretty much done another
surgery am i yeah oh no putting the tube
money in the drain my hair so I don't
have [ __ ] flamengo no more so I have
this [ __ ] dizziness oh that's scary
yeah it's for
and scary so I'm done I'm done hi for
the last [ __ ] three months I've been
working out with earplugs really I gotta
fly with earplugs not on I just have to
chew gum on the [ __ ] plane but when I
shower I have to have earplugs I don't
know what you could blow the [ __ ]
house up have two ties to back off in
the shower I can't nobody it plugs on me
heart beating [ __ ] turn off and then
I got a wet [ __ ] plugs when I left or
leave any elliptical on the weekends I
want to go to jujitsu I don't hate the
timer and it's horrible because you hear
yourself breathe you actually hear your
heartbeat so it took me like a month to
get used to so in the idea of big year
like what is the what is the issue who
the [ __ ] knows I don't know okay now is
going into the [ __ ] deep deep deep
deep into the year and then the water
stays in there and then after a few days
my hearing goes so I get anxiety because
like if I'm on a room it takes a certain
size room and when people talking
mushrooms I gotta run out of there
because all the sound goes into my one
ear and it makes me have panic attacks
like epic calmly story original those
type of rooms give me panic attacks
rooms that size when I'm going deaf plus
my equilibriums off so I feel like hella
my might I got sick on the way to Rogen
I got sick on the way back from Rogan I
felt sick on the way back with you from
the play San Diego Oh yesterday
yesterday I got sick on the way home
that's why I was quiet in the car for a
while and then I was sick the other day
just going over the [ __ ] Hill so I
went to the doctor this is it like I'm
starting to get carsick now like my
daughter I'm regressing to that [ __ ]
thing again so I don't puke I just get
that feeling like you get you're about
to y'all pull over and open the windows
and you see how open the windows on the
air yes yeah
that means I'm starting a car sick oh I
thought my next smaller company Donna
so it's [ __ ] weird you gotta take
care of this [ __ ] this is it you know
when you get to a certain age you're 3
year 36,000 mile warranty wears out and
you're on your own after that pop oh
yeah we were talking about that
yesterday once and I spoke with my mom
cuz she had like 30-something developed
like outdoor allergies never had them in
her life she sees its lactose-intolerant
now we're talking about that lunch how
you can just things just change she's
affects people oh my god it's weird they
started this [ __ ] somebody started a
church or what's happening now page on
Facebook yeah and it's either a dud or
it's really really good somebody started
it his arguments there you know people
hating on me people hating on Rogan it's
hysterical but the funny thing is enough
from time to time to get somebody
posting something pretty pretty honest
on there and you go wow that guy gets it
you know
and yesterday somebody posted something
about being 23 and he was kind of
shell-shocked you know [ __ ] wasn't
working out right everybody wrote
different things you know when I thought
about it I sent them something I wrote
something on that who assesses what his
life you have to step back assess and
take a look and work on those areas you
know and that it's [ __ ] petrifying to
me being 20 again you know the most of
the people I was into this podcast I'm
getting out of college or just turning
30 the [ __ ] ideal of it right now in
today's world scares the [ __ ] out of me
sometimes when I bust your balls Lee
right I'm busting your balls cuz I'm
scared for you I know what if what the
economy was like when I was growing up I
lived with different hustles you know
when I was young you didn't have to be
well-educated or educated there was
people who went quit high school and had
high-paying jobs you know in union halls
or using carpentry or [ __ ] like that or
but they became stockbrokers or whatever
the [ __ ] that is but there was also a
low-end thing there's people who don't
want to not only does some people want
do everything right and what if those
people want to be doctors right you know
Trump wanted to do this you know
everybody wants to do something but then
some people just want to coexist I was
always one of those people that was very
happy by coexisting what does that mean
if you need 600 fferent to order for
your car payment and
three other for groceries you make a
hundred dollars more a month in that
like I was pretty satisfied to live my
life like that I can't live you and you
didn't have anxiety about running out of
money
you always have anxiety but I thought
that I wouldn't have it for life so I
just got used to it but that anxiety
makes your heart beat to make sure get
up off your ass right yes you [ __ ]
brain-dead I was thinking about that
today like some whenever I have like a
job I didn't like or something I if I
cook every time I was worried about it I
quit it's not not magically but
something would come along like a couple
times it happened that very day like the
day I quit I got a call for another job
and I think I think what you're saying
it's very true for 20 year olds I think
it's also true isn't it true you change
your career like seven times throw your
life so what if you're thirty five forty
five unless you get five six times right
and then you have to change your [ __ ]
career I don't you know I can't see you
changing your career like take Paula for
example right
how long is Paula gonna be for an
eternity for and then what point is she
gonna switch [ __ ] careers oh she just
you did seven [ __ ] years and the hell
on the college and paid two hundred
grand three hundred grand for your
education I mean I don't think people
like that switch careers maybe not
people like that but I think I like
people who only have like I think now
they're like the people who used to only
get high school degrees and bachelor's I
think now bachelor's is like the minimum
and then you you have to get mad
master's degrees now a lot of people but
I think if you have a bachelor's degree
like my degree is essentially worthless
it's good if I wanted to go back to
editing but I have a degree in digital
post-production so that's I can't go I
can't he I can't get anything with that
so that I think that's the kind of
person that would go and do insurance
and then go do sales somewhere like it
just I think I think it I think it was
heaven can scary world man when I think
about it my city and uh you know I have
a daughter now and I said like what the
[ __ ] is her world would be like and
that's why I teach her the value of a
dollar earlier like I'm trying to
[ __ ] do things better like she's
already getting a lot of stuff
she's getting it guys you know I got a
Radames big boobs for a certain reason
explain one that reason was and I
explained to her why I go to work and I
show with nickels and dimes and pennies
and I show her a dollar bill you know at
this age just so she could grab she
doesn't grabs but she doesn't understand
the work thing and paying rent you know
but I'm trying to let her know that's
why I'm gone that's why I have to leave
cuz I'm going to work I'm not going on
[ __ ] party or something like that
yeah I don't know about you but I think
you've spoken about this for other
things but when I first moved to LA I
learned from a lot of mistakes I saw
other people making with their money
that was just like they were going to
debt consolidation and then they're fine
now but if that freaks me out when I
first got here the thought of having
that much debt credit card debt that you
have to go and get another loan and
consolidated to one payment well I got
divorce my credit card debt was
definitely over a hundred credits Wow
well at the end and after everything I
was definitely over 200 grand deaf boys
definitely are you serious definitely
over how long how long a period like did
take build it up a year I went off the
rails
funny I bet this is that expression of
walking on ice you might as well dance
right it fits a variety of different
phases in your life and you'll know when
you're there you know you'll know when
you're there it means that you're going
for it you know [ __ ] going to work from
8:00 to 5:00 I want to be the best
stockbroker that I'm gonna go from 6:00
to 10:00 at night you know you walk on
ice you might as well dance you're
already there anyway right make money
pay attention it could go the other way
so I was so down and out and I was so
devastated like when you get a
devastation in your life it's very hard
to focus a divorce a bad accident with
somebody else in the car or maybe you
alone a death of a family member it
consumes your brain over time no no all
the time
whenever were the effects were they
become something else and they become
that you can't focus I was watching
something yesterday about a kid who was
there who would only only survivors in
this class and Sandy Hook so what he had
to go through like he couldn't leave the
house for 70 days for seven months a
seventy day seven months he only vows
the only way he ingested life was with a
football now on the other side of that
token there was a football play at the
University of Colorado that was there at
the movie theater when the kid went nuts
that night watching Batman right they
were watching so he also but that little
kid slipped on blood on the way out of
the classroom he was a [ __ ] first
grader that's seven I think right yes
lost a seven so you they they taught him
how to get him back and one of the
things he was saying was that he
couldn't focus because the experience
was so traumatic that you can't focus on
the most menial things I swear to you
Leanne you know me a long time there was
a point there where like where I could
get up but I couldn't do nothing if it
wasn't from the help of a dear friend of
mine named Danny Feebles
that kept sticking me to come to his
work and work he didn't like make your
own hours but just you have to do
something you can't just sit in your car
at 12 go eat Chinese and then rent the
movie and then go to the gym and then go
home that was my life after I got
divorced then that LAN I go out and get
high and you don't hit on girls whatever
the [ __ ] but I wasn't doing anything in
my life and after six months he got to
me and he goes you're gonna see how easy
it is to make money and there was he was
right I made money the first [ __ ]
week I made money working with him but
before that I was a good salesman
I was very detail-oriented and I lost
all that for six months because of the
effects of the divorce and the trust and
the [ __ ] thing with the kid it really
hit me hard
you know or hit me hard and usual when I
got out uh when my mother died three
years after she died the effects of the
death the the pain whatever the [ __ ] you
want to call it the grief it became a
man
fasten to something else in your mind
and when I quit high school my senior
year nice well I don't want to quit high
school just because I couldn't focus on
it
I couldn't even focus on that like I had
so many things going on in my life but
the number one thing I knew was work I
had to generate dollars nobody was
giving me any money I could go to high
school and be broke or generate [ __ ]
dollars yeah I could go on well for his
[ __ ] like that I was too young and too
strong to go on any of that [ __ ] you
know and and like when when you say you
had all that stuff were you depressed
and thinking about the stuff you were
going through it or is it just like your
brains wasting you just can't focus the
brain isn't racing your brain is you
kind of feel brain dead it was a
depression of sorts it was a depression
if you look at what it was a
manifestation of oppression that I went
through I went through out some divorce
with my wife I went through what after
the death of my mom and I kind of went
through it when I was here because of
everything I suspected about my daughter
and how my life was going to turn out
came to a reality and that put me
through a different depression if we
listen to Rogan he'll always say that I
got funny one day like for a while I was
just funny but then I just blew the
doors off it was because I shook that
little depression that I had it was over
it was a combination of a lot of things
it was pain it was anger it was
frustration and I just shook it you
talked a lot about in comedy
specifically how it you you've been
successful for a lot of reasons but one
of them is just because you've stayed
for 20 that's it that's the number one
reason but do you think like obviously
you're working hard at it but do you
think the other part of it is you kind
of just have to wait yourself out like
you have to wait until you as a like as
a person have grown enough to be able to
work hard I like to get past all those
things that just happen in your life
well like I was telling the dude on
Facebook you have to assess your life
you have to assess your life every
[ __ ] 90 days you know and I was
trying to assess my life but I thought I
was wasting my time because
the cocaine got rid of the assessment
right you know right now I could assess
my life even though I smoked a lot of
marijuana or whatever people may think I
could assess my life and make the right
little adjustments like I've done over
the last 10 years it's November 1 in
like seven or eight days or what is the
claim of his birthday like tomorrow or
the day after okay that's one of the
time I started like I didn't get high
now at all know them and then I really
quit this will be ten years but you know
I had to make assessments when I tried
to make assessments of my life when I
was getting high it wasn't gonna work
cuz I was getting high cuz you and
you're making the assessments when
you're sober yeah but I'm still getting
high the fumes of that cocaine will
always help to make or destroy that
decision that what you're lacking of and
it could be for opioids this is all the
same it's not just I don't want people
all he's talking about Colby propio it's
it could be from Mara it could be any
you know I've learned to be a
functioning addict with marijuana as you
noticed like they just spurts me it
makes me even strong it's like a steroid
for me how people complain about
steroids and if they drug tested in
comedy I would be dead right because I'd
be wilder I would be untamable on stage
I would be unattainable and I would
eventually just die on stage come one
night because I just let it all out
you think it calms you down on stage
yeah calms me down holy [ __ ] okay you
know I would go off for reals I can't
want to see that now no you don't want
to see that that's why I don't [ __ ]
around with it I keep it there maintains
nobody get their feelings hurt
it keeps the grease going right you know
there's times I get high and everything
don't get high but by me taking to it to
the joint it keeps the grease going a
group keeps the [ __ ] oil flowing you
know sailing everything keeps the
machine you don't ever break that
machinery you don't stop them it'll
never stop the machineries so but it's
funny that I made assessments over the
years I didn't start making big-time
assessments though towers in my third
but that's why I felt like I was lying
to the kid in a way because who the [ __ ]
was I kidding I didn't start making real
assessments but I got a prison prison
was the first time I ever got a chance
to look at myself from another situation
and it wasn't good either because I was
in prison so no matter what assessment I
made I was still in prison are you with
me right so I don't no matter what
assessment I was making about myself and
what I wanted to do when I got out of
there or what I needed to work on all
bets were off
I was locked the [ __ ] up but wasn't it
like the clearest you've been in 15
years or I don't know I don't know me
doing that like I say when people go to
rehab and they think they're gonna get
healed they're lying to themselves you
basically playing praying for a retreat
that's the way it takes people a couple
multiple rehabs tante yeah because they
really have to think about what's going
on well if I pull you out of your
environment and you got a chance to look
at your environment from the outside
looking in you'll see and off the drugs
you'll go oh my god that's why I was
slipping why was I dating that person or
you'll come to a bunch of conclusions
you'll go why the [ __ ] was I doing that
why was I doing that I don't even like
that person why am i working out of
chicken place I don't even like [ __ ]
check it
blue cheese not only good but things
just happen so quickly when you're in it
then it you just just let it all pile
right so again we go back to if when you
walk on a nice you might as well [ __ ]
dance right you know what I was doing
drugs that was in a rocket ship they
couldn't be any lower than I could get
so keep doing it really this is as bad
as it could be for me I'm gonna keep
doing it and it didn't it when you
realize it was as bad as it's gonna be I
didn't realized who use [ __ ] lanes if
I met you guys I was talking on a
podcast one day that I had even lived in
a [ __ ] rocket ship so to you it was
just like I can survive this yeah it was
just another day in the [ __ ] jungle
for me I didn't remember that till I
started [ __ ] around with you guys
that that was so painful that that got
swept under the [ __ ] rug it was until
one day we were doing a podcast and I go
do the way he's living a [ __ ] rocket
ship and you pop your head up by what
Joey what the [ __ ] what did he just say
no I used to you know sleep at that
[ __ ] rocket ship in ADHD Park that's
one of the things I've really enjoyed
about doing therapy the last few months
is and I'm cuz I've always been I don't
know I get in my head a lot like oh I
don't they don't want to hear this or I
don't want to I don't either I don't
even they don't want to hear it or I
don't trust them enough to tell them
things so just like start getting to say
certain things that I've only thought
about before have it just has made it
like less important in my head like I'll
say like she'll ask me a question and as
I'm going to answer she's like why is
that a big deal and I'm gonna think
about it and as I'm thinking of the
anthem I go wait maybe it isn't that big
of a deal but just it keeps going around
in my head and it never had a chance to
get out so it cake kept growing and
growing so I have this stuff listen I'll
tell you some experience
half the stuff that goes through our
head isn't even important I'm telling
you this I'm telling you this [ __ ]
experience it doesn't matter because in
our minds we have to [ __ ] do
something we love being somewhere in a
certain [ __ ] space and time and for
some people they love the [ __ ] drop
and that they don't have drama but they
add so [ __ ] drama yeah that's always
the weirdest one for me people who
always I worked with a bunch of them who
would always come in and they're always
like in a huge fight with somebody I I
never understood that like I even I
would purposely avoid those things
happening and it seemed like those
people every every few days had someone
else it's I just I hate I hate when I
read or you know when I answer emails on
the podcast and [ __ ] people hit me up
on an email about a situation somebody
emails are just playing but some things
that people post sometimes about
themselves all those send me something
personal I could feel it I could feel
what they're going through because I was
there like I could read that kids
writing on that
and I understood I went back to 1985 and
I went back to being 20 [ __ ] 3 in
1986 and you know living in San
Francisco and going to bed every night
not frustrated and confused 23 I was
frustrated and confused which is a
[ __ ] horrible combination and scared
you know I was frustrated confused and
[ __ ] scared I was like those naked
people in the woods that they put child
on that show on a any naked and afraid
out there I had clothes and I was naked
and afraid but I [ __ ] now I fake the
funk like I faked myself through the
[ __ ] like I was 23
petrified I'm just getting out of Bergen
ok just getting out of Jersey yeah ok
when I was 23 it was 1986 I lived in San
Francisco I lived in Boulder for a while
and I lived in Snowmass Village when I
was 23 years old doctor alright so I
like if I think the my class and I
thought about this I had like I didn't
have a grasp in all three places like I
had no grass I had a job you know I made
it seem like I had it together but I
really didn't have it together by no
means I would put money away and I'd
blow it I took classes at night but I
really wasn't doing anything with my
life did you feel like you're headed
together in Jersey no I didn't have it
together anyway I couldn't [ __ ] get
it together if you built it for me and
put it in front of me and put it in my
[ __ ] pocket that's how much I was a
self deterrent to myself like I would
just step on my own constant right when
I was right knocking on the door I could
[ __ ] up our wet dream like I was just I
was [ __ ] everything up till maybe
thirty something till maybe thirty
something I was a wet dream honey and
you know what I got by you know somebody
hit me up the other day if I knew some
guys from the car business or whatever I
always
and I was thinking being the car
business on my first check like taking
home like four grand and thinking like
that said thirty-six thousand a year
this is perfect for me like I was like
that's it I didn't like the dry cleaner
I give her the June me like I don't like
the dry cleaning I'm like [ __ ] mother's
dry clean suits five suits a week but
y'all look good you got to be clean you
see now you're were a suit the second
day looks like [ __ ] so I was content
with dirty $6,000 I didn't know that I
could do more than that I didn't even
and I was making more than that to be
honest I was making seven grand a month
but after taxes it was like $4,000 right
so I was making like whatever the [ __ ]
it was 84 grand I could have made that
year and when I went over to Dodger I
lost a little bit of that income but I
was working less hours with less stress
so I knew I could survive that let me
know I could survive by wearing a shirt
inside that I like it
no no I didn't like the [ __ ] I didn't
like the feeling of being a car salesman
but it paid my bills and what I didn't
know was happening was happening I was
learning about life in a weird way I was
really getting an education of people
which is the education I always saw it
after but you know I thought you I
thought you would a lot I thought you
loved it I didn't hate him like it
listen when your wife goes to a party
with you as soon as she says I'm gonna
attorney somebody's gonna make a room or
there's just something about being an
attorney right or wrong ya know being an
attorney they're all scum and there's
some about being a car salesman ah I
already was insecure about being a thief
and a piece of [ __ ] a junkie now I gotta
throw a car salesman on the mix if you
don't saying so I just didn't and I have
nothing against cross out I hope someday
when I retire from this [ __ ] I could
sell cars again when I'm old
that's some people buy cars with you
when you're an old man people feel bad
for you you give them some knowledge hey
what's your the guy in the longest shot
that was made by this dodge for me
[ __ ] oh I call this a [ __ ]
you know I love
to sell cars again but at that time at
the age of twenty something I was like
[ __ ] so I'm a [ __ ] thief or junkie
and now I'm selling cars this is perfect
for y'all like I like that angle of it I
just didn't think I'd do it the rest of
my life if that's what you're asking me
okay that's surprising but is it getting
back to what you're talking to well it's
like confidence like I don't I don't
think that I come off at all like I had
a jaw I came out here I got a job and
stuff but I don't think I come off as
confident at all and hearing because I
just imagine you at that point I would
have a mag I'm picturing you as very
confident no I was scared
really I was scared which made me
confident but I was not confident she's
big difference
it's called faking the funk yeah I can't
fake it big difference I was petrified
but I didn't have time to be petrified
are you with me like that and my I
couldn't do it there was no reason to be
petrified I had it and little by little
it wasn't that I picked up self
confidence in me
I just wanted self confidence to know I
could [ __ ] survive well I left New
Jersey I had Timmy and I had Roger and I
had Glencoe and I had a bunch of friends
you know when I left I leave on great
[ __ ] terms so they were always there
if I got into a pinch what's a pinch you
need a friend you know a bus ticket you
need 200 hours to do something but they
couldn't pay my bills so that's what I
was forcing myself to do when I left New
Jersey was to teach me how to take care
of myself I already knew I just was
trying to pull it all together catch I
already know I'm a bank accounts I read
about light bills phone bills credit
cards you now you have to put it all
together now you have to make a certain
amount pay a certain amount pay for your
own groceries everything becomes
different you're not at Mom's house no
more you if you've learned that over the
years you know a couple years ago it was
a big difference you know yeah it was
and there was something that just came
out recently that people were talking
about
that they're saying by 30 you're
supposed to have one like whatever you
make a year that you're supposed to have
that put away for your retirement by 30
but I don't I don't know anyone who has
that I don't I wasn't even thinking
about retirement if 30 no I was thinking
about being thirty seventy year 2000
will I make it at thirty I wasn't
thinking about [ __ ] with time and
playing the Social Security or [ __ ]
all I knew is I paid into that [ __ ] and
it pissed me the [ __ ] off
it does yeah when you first get checks I
know you see that 80 hours out of your
[ __ ] out of your four hundreds gone
that's a bunch of [ __ ] boy do you
get pissed until you get fired and
getting unemployment and you know why
they pay me this much because you put
away anything like man I'm happy I pay
them for that [ __ ] unemployment yeah
at that point but it's uh my survival
was all I wanted Lee that's all I was
now looking for perfection I was not
looking to time ago a kid I had a
roommate that was kind of one of those
geeky kids that would get up once a week
little thing called Toastmasters oh I've
heard about that can you push it up just
to see I don't know I shouldn't say it's
geeky I don't even don't really know it
is he was geeky that's what I mean to
say he was one of those guys I was doing
blow I was selling cars I was lifting
weights I had a girlfriend I really
wasn't doing much of my life I had a dog
and we lived together in South Boulder
and he would get up early and go to
those Toastmaster things and he was
college educated but he didn't have a
job and he had motivation things all
over everywhere you know saying like no
my only motivation all cards or some
yeah he got him everywhere there's room
like every time I go to his room was
like Jesus [ __ ] Christ
what is wrong with this guy and when
they came into my room we were talking
he goes how come we don't have nothing
to wake up to in the morning and I know
when he taught me
have something to wake up to the more
than eleven I don't know what do you
mean you know you gotta wake up every
morning and put something and funny that
you see that you want
and he goes what is it that you want I
didn't know what the [ __ ] you was
talking about yeah I don't know either
I'm like what do you mean and he goes
what do you want out of his life like he
was I think a year younger than I was I
mean he was really sharp he always wore
shirt a tie he didn't have a job I mean
it could've been that shot but he always
was applying for a job but he was
talking about investments and [ __ ] I
don't know even today I don't know if he
was a stroke and I believe is very
what's that word when you have those
things around your wall like wake up
today what you pay for today will come
to you tomorrow
all that [ __ ] so he came into my room
when they saying you gotta put some up
in your room so my three days lady came
up he goes hey you know if I come in and
he put up a picture of a Testarossa all
those cars right he taped stapled it
stapled it my thumb tacks it for the
wall and they said this is what you have
to look at every morning before you
leave the house because this is what you
want I didn't want no [ __ ] Testarossa
that's the last card ever [ __ ] jump
into first I probably would fit in one
of those there's no more than the module
I just don't like those type of cause
I'm scared anyway so it was just I
looked at him weird at that age but
years later I understood what he said
it's like writing goals what the [ __ ] do
you want you know I didn't know anything
about goals till Djem handy won't say
out of a prison and I met Jim Hanley you
had a new gold there every day at this
car dealership you're gonna hand them in
before you go on the line which means
before you answer the sales call before
you to the customer you had a hand your
goals in and he would suck and hold you
to it still where your goal was for the
day yeah so let's say you get there and
by the time you were there I was all
ready to buy a car from you right he
would [ __ ] cut that deal in half
until you wrote your goal so you had a
sit with the customer no hold on one
second let me just write this down
because of not had adequate he would
give it to me you know we take them on a
demo right
writes his goals he was that serious
about it yeah but he had listened Lina
must have believed in it him being that
serious about it
is why I'm still [ __ ] here and bottle
of Riesling in the door what the [ __ ]
I'm doing though because I stuck to that
I got I got locked up came out and
bumped into him and I didn't start
writing them told just about comedy
maybe maybe no I'm lying to you guys I
did him while I was working for him and
then I stopped and then when I started
doing comedy I started doing them again
like in 95 96 I dueled for monthly goals
or weekly colds or I want a TV show by
the end of the year I still [ __ ]
write about every year and then record
it and it just keeps and I think what
your roommate was doing in it sounds
like it's a good idea is just making
sure you remember so you don't get lost
in the dailies thing what are we what
are we working for yeah well that's part
of it I mean it's easy listen some jobs
are great you got a job with your
buddies you [ __ ] go after when you
drink right I figured there were your
buddies you go to work till 5:00 5:30 do
you learn a few drinks and you go home
sometimes you meet your friends
sometimes you meet a girlfriend you
really don't think about putting away
money I mean there's just so many
[ __ ] side tracks that you have when
you're a young man you know especially
if you're not a college educated
especially you can't [ __ ] afford
college right I mean what's college
costs today I don't [ __ ] know but
fifty thousand a year everything on a
state school a lot of a lot of those so
for me to go to Valley College up the
corner here oh that well that's a that's
a that's a what is it called a Community
College and you'll still get a good
education
oh yeah that's and that's a smart way to
go now is to go two years there do all
your gen Ed's like your math your
English science or everything there and
transfer and then do your major and a
better bigger school because that it
will cut your it will cut your bill in
half essentially
you know I don't even know school is the
answer for you and let like for me I
liked it and I really want I wish
listen my life with a gal is planned how
would I got know a four-year college you
know I would've gone to a four-year
college for sure that's what I wanted if
I could do it all over again I wish I
click on a four-year college got to a
nice law school become an attorney made
a nice living right 19 books I could
have done that
hello it sounds like call it to me I I
see elegant colleges look there's a lot
of things in this society that we almost
have to do just otherwise it's like we
don't get to play almost so college now
I mean there are a lot of people who
don't get to go to college but I've
heard a lot of jobs now if you don't
have college you can't just you can't
apply and I like I've been thinking
about it there was someone talking and
they said that you you don't know what
you want to do because you just haven't
experienced enough and I think I think
probably it would be like I think there
will be a lot of people used to take gap
years ago traveleurope like I didn't I I
just rushed right in to college and I
rushed right into working I didn't take
any gap no brakes at all like less than
a week between both I didn't take no
[ __ ] gaps either but that but then
you also had you weren't you didn't you
didn't go right into like a nine-to-five
job you went into entrepreneurship
essentially so what are you saying that
people need gaps I think so I think or
just like you're saying like if you
don't need college maybe you need to go
what all right what do you think you
want to do I said you don't listen this
is what my argument is okay because
everything you like is always something
to do with time wolf and that's where I
don't like time off but it's know
there's only working but like let's say
you want it to be a lawyer right going
and intern at a law firm see if you like
it if you wanted to be a chef go and be
a server know that's what people do
right there's our people no I think I'll
be able is gonna call yeah no no but I'm
I thought you meant we pull in an hour
like one year it's the [ __ ] it is sunny
nice but what you want to do what your
[ __ ] life I think this too much of
that I think there's too much of that I
think that and then there's there's gaps
later I think that after I my personal
feeling is I have a daughter and the
farm alive I would try to talk around
going right to college I like a
first-year high school right I would
talk her into getting into a college the
thought and just saying I'm taking a
year off first to get a regular job
she'd go over the house I'll pay the car
payment first she can live at the house
one year one year to date a regular
[ __ ] job ticket sales retail a
library something to understand the
value of the dollar to see what's really
out there and what really works you know
I still believe in the old-fashioned but
I still believe that a person who
doesn't have to go to college I think
that a person could especially what I
what I've noticed around me in the
situation I'm in now I know this other
person who doesn't have to go to college
but a person could still be very
successfully I believe that I believe
that if a person goes to work at 18 and
pays attention to his job or gets a job
that he really enjoys after 10 8 9 years
he could buy into a business or start
his own little business on the side with
his philosophies about that business I
think that's a really feel that I've
always believed in that I come to work
for you as an electrician 7 years in I
could do this in my eyes closed I could
do this with my eyes closed okay I'm a
registered residential Wyman I also have
a commercial license I know how to
[ __ ] put the [ __ ] boards on the
poles I know everything question you
need a master electrician to open up a
[ __ ] business so it's like it's
levels you know I'm just talking
electrician
so you think you could be a great master
electrician without really being a
master electrician so you've got a
higher master
trician pay him is rate you could still
sell jobs and hone the business
gotcha but you don't need to get to the
match electrician level no but you have
to have one to open up an electrical
shop and I'm just saying you know for
all these things there's always people
that have been hustlers I've gotten to
work for somebody have learned the trade
eight nine ten years if I come work for
you at the age of eighteen and I do a
ten year apprenticeship not an
apprenticeship just come to work for
your dad's clothing store if Dick syat
had the biggest [ __ ] men's fashion
ear in Boston and he sold upgrade suits
and [ __ ] if I came to work for you at
eighteen I'd start in a stockroom in the
back you know hanging [ __ ] up stocking
shelves you know inventory that stuff
after a while you might make me a sales
assistant then a couple other years a
registered dude and that's a night you
make me a [ __ ] salesman of system
manager manager now I'm the general
manager that can happen well I mean that
could happen in today's [ __ ] war I
won't mention any names but up at one of
the common clubs up here where we did a
live podcast one of the sons little
started out as a sound guy his first day
and now he's managing the club and I
think it's like three or four years
later that's like it's so that does
exist you're absolutely right no because
people don't want to put the time in
like I totally before the show
okay so this guy's 23 guess what guess
what he would have just been getting out
of a 48 inch in the army
yeah you know another big [ __ ]
mistake I made that everybody [ __ ]
makes because you don't you look at I'm
telling you guys that this time goes
something fast when people look at you
when you when you look at something you
go you know what I'm really interested
in being a window cleaner Holly really
Joey yeah because I'm not scared IDEs
when I remember when I went to Statue of
Liberty I climbed on the thing and home
I don't give a [ __ ] about Heights okay
so what do you need to do I'm saying
like it just all we told her look people
don't want to put the time to time
the time the time always scare the [ __ ]
out of you when I tell you about time
when I look you in the face when you
come to me I'm this line go John I've
seen it would I see it all the time with
young comics nobody is more of a
pessimistic pricks than young comic male
or female alike when they ask you how
long it takes to get good well I mean
that that one must be one of the harder
ones and I think it's because like at
least for me I liked when I bought one
in other jobs where you get like
reviewed or a boss will say good job
this and that it has a comic you have
none of that you folks for tell you just
one day someone calls you and starts
asking you to head like dog when you're
a comic you make a nightly assessment
about your life when you're first
starting out the first five years antes
them even beyond that my first seven
years every time I got off stage I made
a new assessment about my life think of
that think of that your assessment is
made on how you did on stage that night
yeah but yours mine right like mine
think about if I like that time I went
to San Francisco with re about six five
years ago right you with yeah I'm one of
the nine I [ __ ] bomb on Thursday and
then Friday two shows just [ __ ] bond
like I was getting them but not really
they weren't buying my [ __ ] I wasn't
putting the best [ __ ] out at that time
at that time my [ __ ] really wasn't
together but son Saturday night late I
[ __ ] lit him on fire that they
couldn't even [ __ ] leave Yellowknife
road to that I came on Saturday and you
had the Early Show and we were up as
upstairs in the green room and you're
just like yeah man [ __ ] it no I'm just
gonna go out on this show and I was like
okay I gotta like I don't remember I
think we were doing the podcast it's
like okay and then you just tore them
apart and I remember thinking like and I
thought like why like well I I didn't
understand like the the difference
between going at them and not going at
them
are you there it seemed like you were
doing similar things both shows but like
why what took the thing what caused you
to have the jump I guess anger
frustration the frustration of bombing
four shows in a row what are you doing
what are you doing wrong right right
away a sane individual would say to the
audience fault me I blame it on me
because I myself whatever the [ __ ] you
call that deprecating no because I know
it's not that it's the way I'm
delivering it either I'm not putting
enough heart into the joke either I'm
not stepping into the joke my face
doesn't have the confidence it's a
thousand variables and then you just
make the decision to go and this is the
last show you gotta leave them leaving
with something you got to go one four
five either was a like and I get that
people change but ever since I've known
you to me you're always going so to hear
that you didn't think you were was
surprising what do you mean going like
you would like that to make the change
to go at them and and to pick it up a
little bit to me you're always at that
level I mean maybe not always but in
comedy at least I've never seen you take
a show off in my opinion I'm nervous
like I remember one - the ice at the ice
house at the improv you had a cold and
you were sitting outside in the rain I
said why didn't he just cancel this show
but so to hear that you didn't
personally think that you were at that
level was surprising it's crazy it's
again you make daily assessments on your
comic you have to go home and most
comics like really good comics like Joe
Rogan for example Chris Rock a lot of
these guys go home and listen to their
recordings that's brutal you have no
idea what that's like I listen to that
half of that [ __ ] from the Ice House -
you know it's brutal especially when the
girl raised a hand and so I was talking
about the Vegas victims I hope
my mom is a lawyer my mom is a lawyer
what's that got to do Emma it's amazing
it's just [ __ ] she didn't want to be
there all night and then they didn't
that's why I didn't feel bad see 15
years ago I would have worried about her
for three days afterwards really yeah
yeah okay I don't worry about people
like that no because I know the look on
the face they didn't want to be there
anyway he dragged her there against her
will he made her go that's kind of
calling one of his friends and going
listen I'm gonna go see him was one of
my buddies and laugh and be loose he
took her by mistake which is his
girlfriend his wife isn't me right to
take her but if he didn't plan ahead he
didn't know that she just didn't like me
from the time I got on the stage which
is finally because I understand him like
that not everybody's gonna like
everybody right but it's just that's
something I that listen Ben let me tell
you the most craziest [ __ ] thing in
the world
okay here's I want you to answer this
and I want the people listen an emphasis
what makes a comment pick up his bags
back his car whether he lives in New
York Ohio Michigan Florida Texas what
makes a comedian pack up his car and
drive up to Los Angeles
well have you ever thought of that
[ __ ] question how it like because
this comics don't don't even think of
leaving their respective areas they
never even thought of it they got into
calmly and they saw what it was like I
did comedy with 20 guys in Denver and
those 20 guys there was maybe only six
of us that really liked the road the
other guys we just do Greeley Denver
gigs anything in Colorado and that's it
they have a family they have jobs their
wives have jobs and they don't likes
people in hotels did you know that
there's plenty of those guys and they
each comedy scene do you believe that
that's really the reason why they don't
like to do it
people have weird different tics it
takes a weird person holding it on a
plane and sleeping hotel and stay this
is where we add city for [ __ ] three
days cracking jokes I think that sound
like fun for some people they think it's
brutality you know it must be tough on
women I can't see a girl one of the pack
of bags on a plane by yourself
leave a husband kids boyfriend whatever
and go on a plane I mean you got Hulu
take Kate Quigley you know who doesn't
really have a boyfriend whatever it
doesn't bother how she'll stay out for
he here right but then you have some
real like Mary Lynn who's got a husband
of a child you know when she books films
out of town dude I'm saying with this
it's gotta be weird for a woman you're
alone yeah I think it is weird just
figuring out what works for you
so I think you're right no I don't
listen it's not a treat listen you want
to be a plumber why do you want to be a
plumber I don't know I just thought I
want to be a plumbing them one day like
you know what you don't want your first
day in your job
you [ __ ] unhook that toilet screw it
out pick it up take the seal off and
when you see all that [ __ ] that lives
underneath that you dream of seeing that
no you thought you were just gonna be a
plumber a lot of people don't dream of
smelling that or seeing that I certainly
don't know so once you see that [ __ ] you
[ __ ] that that's why people make you
do the roughest jobs in the beginning to
let you know what you're gonna get your
hands filled with right and at the end
so if you know at that point a lot of
people don't know why they're getting
into things that's the other thing a lot
of people really make they really don't
investing in a career they've been they
somebody told him their uncle was a
fireman and then for years they just
want to be a fireman fireman fireman
fireman they take the test they pass now
they're [ __ ] firemen and that happens
all the time Lee when you pick a wrong
career that's another thing that we have
to talk about because that's a nightmare
and it happens every [ __ ] that and it
has to happen that's why people change
careers seven times because it probably
takes three times somebody who's but not
really because even if you have a
college degree for law okay right when
you have a college degree for law
there's you could do anything right you
could do anything and they'll pay you
more cuz you have a law degree in some
circumstances probably yeah like if your
sales in a sudden you have a law degree
something's we I knew I knew some a
friend of mine in Boulder who we used to
be an attorney and became somebody else
but his salary was a little higher
because he was already an attorney and
he caught him cause somewhere something
[ __ ] we don't know how it worked well
I think maybe what the difference is and
like I had my mom's a lawyer to see your
mother's good alloys as they would yeah
so she'll ever change careers well you
see this is what happens she had a
couple different things when my brother
and I were growing up but I think with
law and maybe with medicine you can have
different specialties like right now
Paul is doing immigration but she could
switch to be like a DEA or something at
some point I think with me I had such a
specific major and I think a lot of
people have specifically I'm going for
ending engineering if you choose long at
that point it's kind of a weird thing to
switch and have really no background in
something I think there's a lot of
people going back to school now there's
a lot of like ink you like what do they
call it boot camps for like people want
to make apps that eventually [ __ ]
laugh that people switch careers seven
times
I must've switched careers 80 [ __ ]
times they obviously look at my resume I
wonder if you get to find somebody's
real resume like every time people file
the [ __ ] tax thing on it it has to be
on your social security somewhere maybe
you can't have access to it but they
must have X oh my god I guarantee I had
at least [ __ ] 55 jobs on paper and
how is in 30 years because since I
started comedy what I have maybe seven
jobs but I so [ __ ] donations for fire
and cops ISIL stickers I sold cause for
a few years you know [ __ ] like that
before that I had at least 55 to 60 jobs
easily cyan and you would just start
from scratch
I mean I would someone similar I guess
for a week and a half I get a wild bug
up my ass don't one that lasted the
longest was the roofing the roofing
lasted three four years I really stuck
with it
I took a couple estimating courses I
took Raya like when the Firestone
offered estimating courses in those days
and the other company we work for the
other rubber company that we work for so
I took all their free seminars you know
I would write them and find that when
they would do with seminars i take a
[ __ ] plane and go to a free [ __ ]
seminar we call it for the plane in the
hotel and then and the company would do
it for free that teach you how to
install their rubber right okay tell me
so it was it was a [ __ ] day let me do
some shout out to you [ __ ] World
Series today Liam Hopkins Sean batten
Mitchell Barton Hargrove candle company
funko Smith black Justine Malik Pepe
Gilmore one by one podcast and my little
Puerto Rican buddy Rene and car seoane
back from helping his little friends
down there in [ __ ] Puerto Rico not
[ __ ] around it's weird man with all
this [ __ ] going on the last couple
months I usually [ __ ] all the time and I
break his balls about watching sports
but I want people to know this that when
it comes to playoff baseball time when
it comes funcle' Joey for years all bets
have been off even last year you were
watching out of our shop for years every
year I do not have the time to sit there
in June and argue with you about the Red
Sox the Yankees I'm sorry I refuse I
cannot do it the sun is shining
[ __ ] the house and watch TV but when
it gets to September and I don't cheer
for anybody I'm not a fan anybody but
along the way you watch and you become
fans of everybody like I like the
Cleveland Indians I like the Yankees I I
love watching the Dodgers you know my
daughter you know your daughter your
kids go to these schools and they cheer
Milan schools now that they can grain
those kids now they're [ __ ] fans for
life yeah they all dress up [ __ ] they
all had a dress in blue today so it's
it's it's kind of weird and I've been
watching and I'll tell you man
after the Vegas shooting and the [ __ ]
two I retains the three hurricanes and
what's going on with the [ __ ]
yesterday in New York you know man the
ones baseball people kneeling in this
country the ones baseball there's no
[ __ ] hitches so far you know and it's
been a great [ __ ] series I've watched
almost every game boat the whole time
I'm gonna watch last couple games and
the games have been very exciting
I can't in therefore this is my sole
route for another team but what makes me
happy is watching like Philippe Philippe
is having he's gone to like three World
Series games he has the he got to the
stadium like an hour and a half early
we're just saying hi there like his
former co-workers he has like a great
time yesterday seeing stuff like that
makes me happy you know and I get like I
said I get a lot of people [ __ ] to hit
me about sports I there's one aspect of
sports that I like that I watch and I
enjoy but there's an aspect when I was a
kid I was gamble and I'd watch six hours
of football and I gonna tell you
something I had to stop somewhere like
that's an assessment you make at one
point you go whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa let's be honest he I'm a
[ __ ] broke dog balae offered me a
hundred bucks to work with him on
Sundays from twelve to three hundred
hours so what am I gonna do what kind of
loser am i no I'm gonna sit and watch
football that's what happens and people
like what are you a [ __ ] loser what
am I gonna do I need 300 bucks here
Italy gives me [ __ ] a yardstick every
Sunday well
so I make 400 a month awfully on a
yardstick I don't watch football who
gives a [ __ ] the only one mess you
missed one game half of a game there's
what I'm saying but people don't really
think that way like I wouldn't think
that way until something like that had
happened now you have to make a quick
[ __ ] call you know you're raised to
work Monday through Friday you know the
only reason I'll work as a comedian I
work Tuesday through Sunday well I got
into this business
it was Tuesday through Sunday Jesus so
one day a week one show Tuesday one
Wednesday one Thursday to Friday to
Saturday one Sunday and if you open up
for Richard Jeni in one of those guys
you did two on Sunday and three on
Saturday cuz oh my god yeah you didn't
[ __ ] around in those days and I could
work I mean I have a backbone of the
[ __ ] Savage the only reason why I
don't work Sundays is because Babu I got
away from the [ __ ] kid I want to eat
with the bubble beside days come on dog
I'm in Cleveland a Sunday during
football season DC New Jersey all of the
cities they [ __ ] watch football they
play football they go to football games
all those bigs you know all those big
cities that have follow those [ __ ]
football teams you don't want to be
there on a Sunday during football season
Lee especially people who went and
bought tickets and now went to a bar all
day and what's the game on TV and now a
hammer that you show at seven o'clock
oh okay no no you have no ideas Sunday's
have always blown from me like as a
comic I'm like what the [ __ ] am I doing
here in a [ __ ] Sunday night like one
time they canceled the Sunday when I was
younger and I was like that's it I gotta
get out of this and then finally like
two years later in Dallas in 99 I was
like that's the last [ __ ] Sunday I'm
working I don't want to work Sundays no
really a day but that old I didn't know
that that night man it's a dead [ __ ]
night if you're real you went out
Thursday Friday and Saturday
[ __ ] Sunday you [ __ ] wiped down if
you and if you
tickets from your gonna be white guys
you're gonna sit there died so we're
just making it better and you go home
and they go home yeah I just did it I
just decided working against [ __ ]
Sunday that was I'm lazy but because I
just didn't see it it didn't pan out you
know Thursday you fly in half way during
the day you go to your hotel room you're
gonna snack you take a shower you do is
show you go back to your room right
Friday you're they're all dead but
Sunday you're there all day that you
already been there Friday all day and
Saturday all of that now you're there
all day Sunday whether it's football
seasons or not and even if it is
football season you're watching those
games what are you doing you're in your
hotel room eating room service
you're at the bar downstairs and Hayley
go do a show on the [ __ ] Sunday house
you're tired - I was gonna say it
sounded like fun everybody's [ __ ]
tired dog especially those days with
plums will pack up your there from
listen when you start a show on a
Tuesday by Friday you're tired then
you're going into the meat of the week
right your busiest days right you follow
me so I liked it for other reasons I
liked it because Monday Tuesday Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday gave you a shot to
adjust your set so better tonight and
add new joke so by the time Friday came
Bob old you later next for seven new
minutes on them plus your [ __ ] is tight
jack how come they don't really have
that anymore was there not as many
comics or the attendance it would be too
rough to get you know I don't know how
many clubs there are to sell tickets on
my [ __ ] Tuesday so you turn it into
an open mic night let the locals
advertise you know get a hundred people
in there make minimum money but you saw
some booze yourself nachos and
everybody's happy Wednesday do a
specialty show what he call those
rapper's delight' what he calls what
they do with the Comedy Store on Tuesday
night ah roast roast battle you do all
that type of stuff on
stay there Thursday you got more blood
flow that's how much T cannot to be
ashamed like I told you we were sat here
and I've discussed with you that way
before your time Monday night was the
biggest night of the week in LA across
the country oh [ __ ] okay because of
Monday Night Football
oh it was the biggest night so 30 years
ago you were going on on [ __ ] Monday
night come hell or high water [ __ ]
you were [ __ ] going everyone went out
everybody went out and now yeah now ribs
meatballs wings every ball would fight
for your dollar chips hamburgers hot
dogs
check bartenders waitresses it would be
something night some booze would show up
and give you free shots
that's a Monday night used to be they
used to be a booze named dr. McCulloh
Cuddy's we talked about this before
people post there where the [ __ ]
chicks would come in and pour the drinks
down your throat in the [ __ ] it tasted
like ghastly you would get sick as a
[ __ ] the next day
oh no but yeah and then the economy has
changed you know there's some people who
go out on Monday nights but then I got a
[ __ ] drink you know it's not like it
used to be Monday Night Football is not
what it used to be in this country
anymore so well it's expensive now I
mean I know I don't know what drunks
were back then but now they're like 10
bucks at minimum
yeah but see Monday nights it was a
dollar a [ __ ] beer you know Monday
Tuesday Wednesday years ago it was
half-price ladies night [ __ ] baboon
night coming with terrorist night you
know there's always some [ __ ] angle
to get you in the [ __ ] door and then
on the weekends they charge you the high
prices I was gonna be there anyway but I
was bored like when I go to Barone's you
know when you go to a place like
Barone's
he makes his new it's a sports bar right
so he makes his money off a football and
all those other events during the week
yeah you got an ESPN game here yes peon
game
but how many people want for those games
not many not many people go out for the
big games on the weekends Thursday night
college football
Thursday night NFL you know I'm saying
you'll see UFC Saturday night people go
out they pay the [ __ ] door charge
it's really weird how the economy has
changed you know I don't know anybody
who really has a big Tuesday night you
know they usually have African American
like they have that night at a club
the brothers going on [ __ ] Tuesday
nights I think that is happening now
though for those events like what you
were talking about is that they're
having more like events for that well I
got when I was in Vegas I said I went to
a bar and paid 20 bucks and and watched
the UFC cuz I think a lot of people
especially with boxing like McGregor was
$100 pay-per-view UFC right now is what
$60 that's expensive if you could go for
20 bucks and then go get drinks or
something somewhere now the fight this
weekend is a pay-per-view or at the
pay-per-view oh yeah oh yeah it's GSP
one of my thing oh yeah he's yeah he's
definitely purview but it's it's
expensive it's expensive to do anything
and then then try to save for even just
not for a retirement just sort of your
life they say I like it [ __ ] every
[ __ ] day from my agents for me to
raise my ticket prices and I give them
grief every [ __ ] day and I say though
because it burns me it burns me had to
let people work [ __ ] hard you know
and it just burns me that the ticket
prices are what they are
some of you offered me tickets for guns
and roses okay four tickets
you ready right four tickets
$2,600 each your total total that's
still on my end in water they asked me
if I knew anybody are you [ __ ]
kidding me when it's right straight
ahead at the forum so it's the second
section straight ed it's not even that's
not front row no row as I looked on
there just to see
from Row area with 1700 oh my god at the
forum they're coming home show so
they're doing like the Staples Center
something else than the forum I looked
at that for six hours and I was like you
know what I could see [ __ ] pain
because and roses six bills for that
section that's gonna be crazy I don't
know if I'll do it I don't think so
that's the guy just called he just asked
me if I knew if I had a friend that he
was selling at face value or whatever
the [ __ ] I don't I don't [ __ ] know I
mean do they still have the original
band members I'm a little yeah yeah no
no that's it's it's the real deal this
is the last of the mohicans this is this
is explosive this is [ __ ] Guns
N'Roses jack well I so how old were you
when you were listening under Moses 87
when they came out on the scene would
happen type of [ __ ] destruction I
still remember that video and then when
I got locked up the third song was big
like when I got locked up sweet child of
mine was the big song welcome to the
jungle had already blown up the airwaves
but now was on something my Michelle was
some [ __ ]
well I got locked up that that was the
album that one Bobby Brown [ __ ] there
was a couple hours that were hot but
that was the big heavy out do you think
you could bring your daughter to what to
the concert not me million [ __ ] me is
what are you [ __ ] no I don't know
there's a four and a half year old girl
gonna get in a Guns & Roses concert I
thought what are you [ __ ] stupid you
just as dumb as these [ __ ] people
that do crazy [ __ ] then they get shot in
the head and they wonder why I would
never bring my daughter on Guns and
Roses [ __ ] concert at four and a half
what's she gonna get out of that Lee I
don't know I didn't know if she's won
any if you wanna know there's no
experience at four and a half it's just
[ __ ] dirty people and loud music she
doesn't understand that in Florida okay
I don't know how what age did you start
writing them in that's no [ __ ] age
let her go and her [ __ ] creepy
friends really yeah let her go one
creepy friends unless she comes to me
and says I want you to [ __ ]
personally take me to a concert
mother goes do that stuff for temple
okay I mean that but I'm not gonna
taking a see nothing until she's 15 and
she knows what the [ __ ] she's getting
alkene okay sure I want to know what
she's getting herself into
I thought you I thought you loved these
like I thought you would just love like
the needs they can want anything not to
bring my four and a half year old for
400 [ __ ] dollars around surrounded by
sixteen thousand people leave when
you're [ __ ] [ __ ] or what well you
hate you hope for that world bricks in
the [ __ ] head maybe no I don't want
to take my daughter another [ __ ]
place just in case how does break loose
I wouldn't bring no loved ones there
that's why I was just asking a question
I didn't know what to take it cause I
don't want to be involved with another
that [ __ ] anywhere where I can't wear
bulletproof [ __ ] vest and a helmet I
don't want to [ __ ] be there you dig I
feel like my days are done I'm 54 gonna
be 55 in February I won't for the gray
one a banana peel and I'm lucky I got to
where I got to the last thing I'm gonna
do is go some [ __ ] way or somebody
might have a piece of shoot me outside I
put a bomb those days are done with my
UFC days all those days that come to a
[ __ ] of that Johnny you get scared
enough when I go through the [ __ ]
Airport to check my luggage and all that
[ __ ] what I'm going through screening
I'm [ __ ] saying a prayer all I'm
waiting for is for some guys in collie
Baba and my [ __ ] dream come to an end
and you want me to take my daughter guns
and roses what are you [ __ ] crazy I
wouldn't do something like that if you
[ __ ] paid me those people who got
shot in the movie theater and took that
kid to see Batman shame on you your kid
don't know what the [ __ ] he's getting
himself into if you want to go with
Batman helmets and be an [ __ ] take a
chance
Columbus did do that [ __ ] on your own
leave your kid with your grandmother so
at least he has a chance in life
so he's the kid has a chance you're
gonna be an [ __ ] and bring your
[ __ ] five-year-old kid to be cool the
[ __ ] out of here I don't even know what
they get themselves into I play music in
the car little loud and Mercy's like
daddy turn this [ __ ] off she doesn't
like it no no no nobody wants to hear
that [ __ ] at the age of four
I don't know I don't know what four and
a half year old listen to him there
wasn't the [ __ ] the ice age whatever
the [ __ ] they listen to Smurfs they
listen to how the [ __ ] thing what's
our the one that they listen to the
other one that drives her crazy all that
[ __ ] doesn't the kids EE okay take it of
[ __ ] I think it was like I like older
people just normally Guns N'Roses still
attracts this is LA you're gonna get
every half-wit rich kid to put on a Guns
N'Roses shirt and rip it and make
believe they even know half the [ __ ]
story that's what they do in LA now
that's what these kids do they don't
know half the history they just want to
be cool and tell their friends they went
to a concert okay so they buy a GNR
shirt they rip it and they go down there
have they ever do a shot of heroin to
the first stop no they ever do an
Eightball the chicks [ __ ] wanna listen
to sweet child of mine know that they go
see the over the radio they even know
[ __ ] use Your Illusion one and two no
doubt it but that's what they do they
get dressed up they wear the outfit and
they go on and make-believe they fit in
okay I found a fan like you who really
is somebody somewhere I really grew up a
fan of those guys he can't afford the
three of our ticket so who do you see
there the conditions all with the getup
on with the [ __ ] I love Pink Floyd
get up you don't know dick about dick
when Pink Floyd was slinging dick you're
playing the organ in Armenia at the
Church of some [ __ ] and you want to tell
me you know but you know I'm saying it's
just fake [ __ ] people fair enough
when you're gonna form a thing you do in
this area here you've got a had that
level of it up it happens in every city
it happens in every city where people
just go and they make believe and they
yeah it was great what the [ __ ] each
other might even play the violin for 30
years you know sailing it's just weird
you don't know what yeah yeah I wouldn't
your love that [ __ ] now every time I
grandiose things their way
I see tons of that [ __ ] do you like
going in Jersey or do you like when I
was a kid yeah no no no I don't go no
way
no way whatta fukk the Lango am I going
ever go no where am I going is a coffee
shop in the weed store that's it that's
all I go home I go to jiu-jitsu I go to
my friends I [ __ ] around with him I lift
weights I don't know YMCA what do I want
to go I don't want to go no one gets
shot Lee not shooting but you know where
we went that was an amazing experience
we're not Robin yeah I had to go get
some [ __ ] clothes that's him
so if you want to buy [ __ ] clothes in
lausanne suit when you travel you go to
Texas when I'm go to Texas I might cause
that twice a [ __ ] here I have a whole
[ __ ] ensemble from Texas why because
Texas encourages the fad lifestyle so if
you're fat you're gonna Texas you're
gonna get the baddest [ __ ] clothes in
the world once you stop going to Texas
is in fat dude your clothes go to [ __ ]
so I got to drive all the way up the
Woodland Hills which is a [ __ ] you
know thank God we won at a perfect time
cuz I got a time to a science it was
like yeah there's no traffic there was
no traffic yelling about 12:30 I went to
the fat man store I got some jeans
couple nights went to sweaters cuz it's
getting [ __ ] cold here and there you
know you only need three sweaters when
you live in LA people that don't live in
that light don't understand that I got
three sweaters and when I go on the road
I bring those three sweaters because
when do I wear those pre sweaters on the
road that's all you need I don't worry
about anywhere else
my mom will ask me right if I would wear
a leather jacket not like know when it's
90 degrees here ya know you don't wish
[ __ ] out here
so all that thick clothes sits if
they're at the bottom of everything and
you never look at it unless you have to
go east right somewhere like Minneapolis
or when I go to Columbus in the winter
and you're and you're going so people
are going man you got last time you were
here you had that same shirt oh I go
yeah that's the last time I [ __ ] ward
like I probably took took this home my
wife washed it I dry cleaned and I never
[ __ ] worn again so attached that's
what [ __ ] happens but to go back to
what we're talking about earlier so
whatever the 23 year old is it looks
like you having a hard time
and I I wish I woulda done certain
things at 23 that I would you know
what's crazy about 23 that it's one of
those ages that even if you know what to
do you still not gonna [ __ ] do it
how I'm just one of those [ __ ] ages
that even if you gave me the map to the
treasure
I still wouldn't [ __ ] get it Lee
that's how bad I was and how unfocused
now undisciplined that was a 20-story I
the more I think about it the more I
think you just need to have the
experience as annoying as it is you just
need to put the time in in life what
Butte when t3 and you're living at home
and you're probably trying to get a job
he's not going for the right job because
what are you gonna do if you get a job
at a restaurant or a fast food joint how
good you gonna feel about yourself how
good you're gonna feel about yourself
you really you can't move out of your
mother's so maybe you're stuck and
that's why I said that you will have to
sit down and you gotta [ __ ] be honest
how are you lazy are you [ __ ] lazy do
you like working well you know my friend
he told me that his uncle had a truck
company he was nothing so what you're
telling me is your weight is nothing
then then your are lazy sack of [ __ ] you
know you ever meet those guys how can we
not work and well because my brothers
cousins uncle said that he's gonna get
me a job in the Union but I wait til
January so it's [ __ ] October what are
you gonna do you gonna sit here with two
[ __ ] months and freeze to death
those guys are like that don't wait for
the [ __ ] job
then they'll [ __ ] I think seeing my
world there was always a job Lee there
has to be I was a loser I was an addict
I was a lot of things but let me tell
you something guys I could get a job in
48 hours I don't know what it was about
me I could always get a job it might not
even be the money one no no no it could
be a labor it would brick
I always knew how to get on the board
you know how to get on the board that's
how you get on the board
and I didn't have to be away like I took
a bunch of [ __ ] like I signed up for
like TGI apps to be a way to course
because they said you had to be a waiter
first to become a bartender yeah so I
said [ __ ] it how about it become a cook
and they go that's another way you can
become a cook and then become what and I
trained them walked out of there one day
the [ __ ] meat was disgusting I was
gonna give that to human beings this is
[ __ ] 30 years ago in Englewood New
Jersey they have like a TV I have
something right off the roof for their
it was an old dumpy spot and I applied
then these idiots gave me a job the
whole time I'm trying to rob the
register that teach me how to be a cook
and how to put shitty food together so
to the general public they were gonna
let you touch the meat yeah they were
gonna train me to be a cook yeah be like
a cook trainee for like three weeks then
you become a cook they start giving your
ships yeah I figured that but you'd like
touched salad than the fries that's how
you start you becoming like a su
whatever the [ __ ] it is yeah but the
[ __ ] was disgusting everything was
disgusting the salad was old I [ __ ]
walked out of there
even back then and I wanted to bartend I
walked out of there I walked out of
bartending jobs Jesus Christ I was never
happy with [ __ ] no job at all I
walked out of high-paying jobs I walked
out of [ __ ] Julian Jones oh my god
you know what I think I'm gonna write a
[ __ ] list of all the jobs I had and
how I [ __ ] quit or got fired I just
didn't give a [ __ ] and if we were just
making up excuses to quit like or didn't
you aw I'd make up excuses on the walk
to the [ __ ] job that's how [ __ ]
bad I was when I went to Colorado got
the old fish's job that made me very
happy for a time being and then I was
bored with it but I like being an
electrician I really did it when I went
it was so weird when I went to New
Jersey the money difference was so
surreal I was a hint I can't do what I
was doing in Colorado for Lester I was
working hard even though I was making
like 12 bucks an hour I was working
[ __ ] hard
they wanted pay me 650 in Jersey for
doing the same job [ __ ] you going
under [ __ ] buildings and you know
getting wiring his [ __ ] and seen dead
cadavers and shoes and [ __ ] rats and
stuff and they'd be [ __ ] raccoons
under fog you gonna you have to crawl
into people's crawl spaces know that
well enough for 656 if to an hour like
as a laborer I was like [ __ ] I was like
that I was like a good laborer I could
install [ __ ] this and that I'd know
how to bend a little pipe give me a
little more nope 650 I was like [ __ ]
that going back to Colorado before going
back to Cali jack and then I went back I
don't even do it I never did it again
I did something else like worked in
hotels or something like that
I was security and a [ __ ] hotel holy
I was a security my last driver at a
hotel who in 1986
who would hire me for a [ __ ] security
job guys oh I was in the prime of my
thieving you understand me I was
stealing things with my eyes before I
had them I was like I'm robbing these
poor people while you're the security
guard
Oh once I became a security guard I had
the keys to a palace it was like kid the
[ __ ] candy stuff I had master keys
and [ __ ] side keys and double keys
Jesus Christ but I never got caught free
clip in there I did perfectly I left you
confused how can you confuse someone
their stuff is gone
though I wouldn't take all of it let's
say you had two thousand dollars of
traveler's checks I'd pick four and you
blame it on your holy you think I'm
missing for love if you had three
thousand in cash I'd take six hundred
you nobody complains about that are they
blaming on the mate
in those days I didn't give a [ __ ] about
the maid wondering your mother man you
know that's how selfish I'd [ __ ]
office I worked for [ __ ] those people
a black talk
on the sidewalks okay the hot tar on the
floor right I work for one of those
people for like two months
her hat what happened there that song
dangerous a score the weirdest thing
happened it was the first job I got when
I moved from Jersey to Colorado had a
whale hard hat the whole [ __ ] thing
and all you did was you had a
wheelbarrow and they shot whatever that
[ __ ] that black thing asphalt asphalt
when you're gonna carry and dump it and
then some little [ __ ] guy would come
over the flat that's all I did
I'm the silent birth of death and they
gave me a pretty good salary they
weren't a cheap there were nice people
but it wasn't the process of me moving
just Snowmass Village this is really
weird so I was embarrassed I don't know
who to ask
it's like you say to me Joey come live
with me just gonna be 600 hours on the
first no it's the first night distance
of holes I couldn't let you down so I
said who can laugh and I said [ __ ] i
harassed the boss because they paid
every two weeks
gotcha hey and when I wrote when I was
writing the I tried to write this story
in there not really I just rolled out as
an outline how I gave him I went there
as a man and I know ain't meant to be a
favor I'm gonna bind I'm moving and I
need an advance they goes well I'll get
me about a week out of corporate I don't
know I need a bit like right now like in
a day or two and he goes well if I give
you the money out of my pocket I go
perfect and he goes what I'll do is give
me the money on my pocket give me a
check Friday I'll cash in no give you
overtime on Saturday I was real cool man
yeah that's really nice alone very nice
the guy the guy was nice to me
throughout the whole time it wasn't a
local company they were from out of
state in some way I don't know what the
[ __ ] they were from so they gave me the
money I'm like a Wednesday or a Thursday
and I got paid on Friday and that guy
didn't show up that day oh so that's
sadly what I went down
nobody was there
and then that Monday I went to work
there would be have been pulled back
something happened I never got a chance
to give the money out of the money back
no man he had to go back to Texas
something happened and they never called
me back
yeah what did you like most about those
jobs like that construction jobs you did
I was 18 I was 19 I was built like a
bull I was living in New Jersey I was
doing nothing with my life now I'm
living in Colorado I'm getting the Sun
and I'm sleeping a little bedroom and I
got like one mattress and I maybe got
five or six bad pants like a couple
sweatshirts and I got may become a pair
shorts and two pairs sneak isn't the
pair winter boots they didn't have a TV
in that room but I had that job and that
was way better than the life I was
living in New Jersey I didn't have any
mice I'd refrigerator you know but did
you like the job itself like did you
find the work satisfying at that age
yeah and then I got a job being a hobby
that was the second time I was a Harley
and I worked for chip chilsen masonry
and that was a great job that was one of
my all-time favorite favorite favorite
jobs and again anytime I like something
it was [ __ ] up well I didn't like
something I could have stayed with it
chip chilsen was a Mason a [ __ ]
really good Mason he had a good scam
going on okay
he was a Mason that did break and but he
had another guy who would fly in from
New Zealand
he was the artiste he was a great guy so
that it was me
chip the guy from New Zealand and
another dude that was a brick mason and
it was me and another hottie and then
you both got promoted and they would
hire other hotties and you became a
brick mason for chip Joseph but there
was a problem
chip chosen was a professional skier so
he would take off every October
so after october [ __ ] 15th you were
dead no matter what you you wouldn't
have anyone take over for him no he will
let a job exist without him on the job
because he didn't want to [ __ ] up his
reputation
oh so [ __ ] that was like that was
that killed me right but and he will
give you unemployment and then he would
call you back like a March that's a long
break and then March you shovel snow for
a month you just shovel [ __ ] snow
right that's it and then I think April
you started building but he would do you
60 hours a week from April till October
he was solid
nothing over three feet you know that
was a great job I was in [ __ ]
tremendous shape you're always moving
you were always outside you're drinking
water
you're scooping with a shovel you're
[ __ ] loading brick eight bricks in
each arm you know kind of two levels
with tongues
you know the brick tongues this [ __ ] I
love that [ __ ] job and at that time
they didn't have that they didn't teach
that course a lot of people didn't teach
because what everybody would tell you to
do was to learn on the job
but at the same time go to a vote tech
school learn how to do it at night so I
yeah you go at night so by the time you
get promoted you're decent and you're a
decent at it yeah and the brick Masons
Union did the same thing the bricklayers
did the same [ __ ] thing they made you
take an apprenticeship program you learn
how to mix mud at college too it
scaffold that whole [ __ ] deal and
then you became a Mason's helper and you
got a raise and when you became a
Mason's helper you would go in the
school the whole time they would pay you
to go to school like six bucks an hour a
night to go to school gives a [ __ ] this
is 20 30 years ago people the Union
would pay you to take courses at the
[ __ ] union hall that's great and the
more of those things that you took it
was better for your career as a union
electrician and like gave you extra
credit district
[ __ ] do you think that's why that's why
I think America's lacking right now I
think America's lacking that low-tech
type of support well don't you think
those kind of jobs I look down upon a
little bit not a brick mason not
teaching somebody I'm not saying you'd
look down
no it's a [ __ ] job guy for everybody
who says there's no [ __ ] jobs that's
a job being a carpenter is a job III
100% agree being a brick mason likes a
job you always talk about like the
people who hang out of the coffee shops
right like those people those parents
wouldn't want their kids to go be like
that's not when they're sending them to
the $30,000 just are listen at the end
of the day right who gives a [ __ ] I
agree what you what you want your kids
to be they're gonna be what they're
gonna be that's normal one of them but
to the option to have that the option
took between the age of 18 to 24 there
being a program cuz there were when I
was growing up right it wasn't the best
but you could go to a local community
center and sign up and somebody would
teach you a trade part-time and they try
to get you a job with peppy electrical
service who would Beach it but they
wouldn't pay you you know saying but at
least it taught you they got you
familiar with the terminology the thing
you're following me I think I don't know
I don't look into those programs but
those are also programs so that I think
the [ __ ] over the years they've been
abolished like the [ __ ] newspaper
read anyway like I told you guys to be
any other [ __ ] show Gotham was sold
out
next week and this weekend in
Oklahoma Omaha Jesus oh ma everything
sold out except for Thursday night so I
don't know what you guys to tell you
know I love you guys and I thank you for
the support always and uh you know if
you like I told you guys we've grown
together so thank you number two like I
told you the beginning of the [ __ ]
show all right
I'm excited that they're back
Thanksgiving there's a time to express
your gratitude and recollect on what
you're truly grateful for right you
invite your people to come over the
house Italy comes over you imagine me
eating and then taking one of the
[ __ ] tremendous half-jew have turkey
shits in your toilet that's why you get
a little tushy birthday for only 69 with
a risk-free 60 day trial you know you
don't want your [ __ ] uncle or yeah
you know like yeah yeah yeah yeah your
niece is [ __ ] married to a fat doing
something like that you don't want them
going in there and [ __ ] destroying
your bathroom with a distinct last
forever and then go through your toilet
paper you gotta cut down a tree forget
about that so she will wash away all
those mashed potatoes with a gentle
stream of water straight to your butt
giving it the best clean that you've
ever had in your life YUM your [ __ ]
muffler Sparkle I mean you want people
to leave their leftovers but not hanging
from their [ __ ] you follow me so
make sure you're ready for the holiday
bum rush with tushy stop wiping with a
[ __ ] nasty toilet paper you may be
your toenail your fingernail goes to the
paper next thing you know your fungo
yourself whatever was a cool finger
fungus whatever the [ __ ] it is
well what I'm gonna do is this make sure
you're ready for the holiday bum rush
with tushy stop wiping that [ __ ]
nasty muffler right with a disgusting
paper got a clean ass I mean sparkling
with tushy so do me a favor go to hello
Trisha calm right now you're gonna
[ __ ] love it all right you got a $69
with a risk-free 60-day trial but days
are back Lee still has his I still have
mine I still use mine Lee still uses his
correctamundo
every [ __ ] day we've had them for
over a year and they're still ticking so
listen for these people that you don't
know what you're gonna get for maybe
you're gonna go to your aunt's house
instead of bringing a bottle of wine
bring a [ __ ] toy she and install it
when you're there so do me a favor go -
hello - she's calm and use the code
Church CH you are CH for 10% off your
order again hello - she calm keep that
muffler sparkling but golden hello - she
calm have pressing code Church CH you
are CH for 10% off your order number -
you ready for this one because this is
my favorite lift is the ride sharing
company that believes in treating its
people better live believes that being a
ride-sharing drivers should be fun and
if you're having a good time
so are your passengers LIF knows that
their drivers are what keeps them moving
so they do everything they can to make
sure their drivers are happy on every
trip I gotta go to the airport tomorrow
who do you think is driving me drop it
on them way left
BAM I don't mess with nobody else lyft
is the way to go besides it's a simple
formula alright happy drivers means
happy past in this maybe that's why 910
lift rides you get a perfect five-star
ready you can earn hundreds of dollars a
week plus tips you want to earn more
money drive more it's never been that
easier to give yourself a raise lift was
the first ride share platform with
tipping built right into the app because
nothing gets nothing because getting
tipped shouldn't depend on your
passenger having a crumpled dollar bill
with blow on it in their pocket or
whatever lift has even taken the
guesswork out of pickups the new web
device uses color coding to help
passengers find their drivers you're
walking down the street you see a nice
lift clock coming at you oh it's the
best at night so beautiful and it tells
you on your app what your what what call
yours is and then when you get in it
says hi and like it for me it says
highly to DeMint this does say hi Joey
so here you go join the ride-sharing
company that believes in Tripa to treat
these people better
go to lift calm / Joey today and get a
500 our new driver bonus that's lift
calm / Joey today and get a $500 new
driver bonus again live.com / Joey
limited time only turbines apply I'm
telling you it's a simple formula lift
dot-com / Joey wait look at the shape
you I want to thank you savages for
listening you know I love you guys Bob
love Lingus Bobby Sharon I mean you know
the list goes on and on I love you saw
with all my heart we'll be back here
Monday with our main man Monday 8
o'clock don't forget about us stay black
we thank you very much have a great
weekend and you people at home have a
great weekend
kick this new leaf